everyone's talking about frozen - but
Disney has been pretty tight-lipped
about the upcoming sequel and what
dangers are coming arendelle's way there
are lots of rumors that the movie will
follow on and Elsa on their quest to
locate their missing parents let's dive
into the truth about the lost king and
queen of arendelle you'll be fine
the king and queen so who are the
parents of Anna and Elsa here's what we
know about them from the first movie
Agner was the king of arendelle it was a
relatively young king he was well liked
and seemed to be a good ruler he was
married to AI Doudna Fayed Elsa first
and honor three years later they loved
their daughter's very much but they
weren't very good at handling Elsa's
powers when Elsa accidentally struck on
it with her ice magic Agner knew what to
do
he found a map that led to the trolls
and asked for help pabbie the head troll
eel Donna and removed all the memories
of Elsa's magic back at home Agner and i
Doudna totally separated their daughters
also was completely isolated from
everyone they taught her to conceal her
powers and not feel anything they
believed that this was the only way else
I could learn to control her powers Anna
was all alone - and she didn't know why
they shut arendelle off from the world
Agner is the one who gave Elsa her
gloves which he said would help her
contain her powers about ten years later
Agner and i Doudna had to leave they
boarded a ship and allegedly left
arendelle to attend a royal wedding but
their ship was caught in a storm and
they were lost at sea
Elsa was in charge of a whole kingdom at
a young age she kept arendelle closed
off until her official coronation at age
21 and that's all we really know about
the king and queen of arendelle from the
first movie but they ends up being quick
to point out a few things the second
movie the trailer for frozen - left us
totally shook it looks epic and kind of
dark all we could really tell from the
trailer is that Anna and Elsa go on some
sort of quest also tries to master her
powers to control the sea we see Anna
falling from some rocks and there's a
new character who has mysterious powers
of their own Anna turns around and
swings Kristoff sword at some unseen
evil we also know that Olaf might be
getting a love interest so basically we
thought this movie couldn't get any more
exciting but we were
wrong because soon after Disney dropped
a crucial piece of information clean I
Doudna is going to have a pivotal role
in the new movie OMG that is so exciting
now this could mean a lot of things it
could mean she appears in flashbacks but
it could also mean that she's very much
alive most people are pretty sure that
the quest Anna and Elsa go on have to do
with their parents they may think their
parents are alive or maybe they just
want to know what really happened after
all they never really got any closure if
they are alive what have they been up to
for the last several years why haven't
they come home the Tarzan theory after
frozen was released in 2013 a popular
fan Theory began circulating the
Internet this theory ties the world of
frozen to another Disney movie Tarzan
Tarzan was released back in 1999 at the
beginning of the movie a young married
couple suffers a shipwreck they wash up
on the shore of some jungle they build a
tree house and have a baby things are
going great until an evil leopard
attacks them a gorilla mom hears the
baby crying she saved him from the
vicious predator and raises him as her
own
Tarzan grows up like a gorilla he later
meets Jean and her father who teach him
how to speak it's a great movie but it
was the shipwreck part that fans honed
in on they believe that the parents of
Tarzan were the lost king and queen of
arendelle
that would make Tarzan the younger
brother of Anna and Elsa now you might
be thinking they don't look very similar
Tarzan's parents have kind of reddish
hair Queen I do know has brown hair and
King Agner is blond but there are some
similarities the men's noses look alike
plus it's two different animation styles
and it happened 14 years apart the
Tarzan theory was confirmed in 2017 kind
of in a reddit AMA the director Chris
Beck said that he thinks the parents
washed ashore built a tree house and had
a baby later he said that is just what
he likes to believe he worked as a
director on Tarzan - he really likes the
fan theory and wants to believe it's
true he said that in his head there are
singing and dancing penguins on the
other side of the island to tie in
Surf's Up
well that just can't be gorillas don't
live on
they live in the jungles of Africa
that's nowhere near penguins
so the Tarzan theory isn't really true
it's just the directors own personal
headcanon or is it maybe they made it
true and on an Elsa will discover their
brother but this theory also presents a
problem for the rumors about frozen - if
their parents or at least Queen I Doudna
is supposedly coming back
the theory won't work that leopard
definitely killed Tarzan's parents it
also looks really cold in the frozen -
trailer it just doesn't get cold where
gorillas live the tangled theory another
frozen creator dropped a big clue in the
very same reddit he was asked where
Agner and I do now were headed when
their ship sank Chris talked about the
Tarzan link Kristen Bell made a joke
about them needing to fix their marriage
in a vacation but Jennifer Lee the other
director said they were headed to a
wedding a wedding for a king and queen
to go to a wedding it's got to be a
pretty important one in fact it's
probably a royal wedding in another
Kingdom now let's take a look at the
guests at Elsa's coronation who do we
see yep that is definitely Rapunzel and
Eugene they came to arendelle for Elsa's
coronation so does that mean that King
Agner and Queen Idina were headed to
Corona for Rapunzel's wedding we know
that historically a lot of Royals were
related and married into different
kingdoms is Rapunzel somehow related to
Elsa and Anna we're totally in love with
this theory The Little Mermaid Theory
Tarzan and frozen aren't the only Disney
movies to feature a shipwreck we love
trying to figure out if all the Disney
movies happen in the same universe we
know that Pixar movies do a popular
tumbler theory links frozen and tangled
- The Little Mermaid
The Little Mermaid came out back in the
1980s but this theory is pretty
compelling a tumblr user named Olaf Hall
- vide use good old geography to prove
her theory
so the Little Mermaid takes place near
Denmark that's the home of Hans
Christian Andersen who wrote the
original story and it just makes sense
with the costumes and characters he also
wrote The Snow Queen which is the fairy
tale that frozen is loosely based on but
the setting of frozen looks more like
another Nordic country it's safe to
assume it's Norway or someplace nearby
and then there's tangled Rapunzel is
German fairy tale and all the costumes
and settings look very German now if you
look at a map you can see that these
countries are fairly close together and
if the king and queen of arendelle were
going to a wedding in Corona they would
need to take a ship that might be why
Rapunzel and Eugene came to Elsa's
coronation they probably feel terrible
that Anna and Elsa's parents died on the
way to their wedding what if the
shipwreck and the little mermaid
belonged to the king and queen of
arendelle that is the right body of
water and it seems to make way more
sense than getting lost and ending up in
the jungles of Africa an even darker
theory okay this next theory about ogner
and i Doudna doesn't tie into another
Disney movie but it does make a pretty
dark assumption in the trailer for
frozen - we see a couple of new
characters one of these is a young man
who's buried in some leaves he gets
thrown up in the air by the wind a lot
of people think this character has wind
powers kind of like Elsa has ice powers
reddit user weakened men posted a theory
a few weeks ago if this guy has wind
powers he might have trouble controlling
them after all we know that Elsa had a
lot of trouble controlling her own
powers what if this guy's wind powers
caused the storm that destroyed their
parents ship he might be accidentally
responsible for their deaths whoa we
know that uncontrolled magic can cause
some pretty bad things to happen and
that would be some serious drama for the
new movie though is clean I dunno now
let's talk about the other new character
from the trailer when this guy gets
thrown up by the winds there is a woman
standing nearby she's dressed in
adventure clothes and she has long brown
hair and it's not on us the hair isn't
right but it is the same color as Queen
I do nose hair is that their mom we
almost missed this connection but what
if Queen I do know has powers of her own
we need to look at Norse mythology for
this one in frozen we know they are a
Norse country because we see Norse runes
and there are lots of Norse looking
symbols in the new trailer I do name
means actively in love that seems sweet
but what if it's more it comes from the
Norse name I do none was a goddess in
Norse mythology choose the wife of
braggy the god of poetry
she was the keeper of immortality apples
and in many sources she's associated
with fertility and love
was also kidnapped by Loki who was
forced to take her by a giant named
Josie what if the shipwreck was actually
just I dunno being kidnapped
what if she has powers like a goddess
that would definitely explain how Elsa
got her powers it would be super cool if
Elsa and Ana's mom is just as powerful
as her oldest daughter reunited we
really want to see on and also reunited
with at least one of their parents but
if their parents are alive why have they
been gone so long it's definitely
possible to survive a shipwreck but
unless they ended up in Africa they
should have been able to get back there
might be some dark sinister plot that
has kept them from returning to their
daughters in arendelle we just don't
know how that could play out but it
would make for a really great story in
the sequel but the reunion between the
daughters and their parents might not be
all happy after all they kind of made
some huge parenting mistakes sure they
might have been trying their best but
let's look at the facts they kept their
two daughters completely isolated from
each other they let Elsa believe she was
a dangerous freak when she was just a
kid this totally messed with her head
Elsa really hated herself and her powers
until she was free in the mountains she
had a ton of guilt and poor Anna she was
tiny when the accident happened she
spent her whole life thinking her sister
hated her she was lonely but it was all
because of their parents and then
there's the whole issue of the prison
cell
Hans traps Elsa in a magic resistant
prison it even has things that fit over
else's hands so she can't use her powers
but Hans wasn't there long enough to
make these in fact how would he know
that all of her power came from her
hands that only leads to one possibility
the king and queen built a custom prison
cell for Elsa just in case they couldn't
control her they were scared of her
powers they had a cruel prison built for
their daughter in case she lost control
was that really the best option the
trolls knew about magic magic exists in
the world why couldn't they just teach
her to control her powers they were the
king and queen they had the means to
find someone to help her yeah we're
thinking this reunion might be a little
tense if it happens do you think on an
Elsa's parents are
still alive tell us your theories in the
comments section below give this video a
big thumbs up if you're excited for
frozen - and before you go hit that
subscribe button so you never miss a
video from us here at the things thanks
for watching we'll see you next time
[Music]